how far can we push the human body
that's a question I've tried to answer
time and time again for Wired's video
series almost impossible that's right at
the threshold I've tried running as fast
as an elite runner trying to break two
hours in the marathon and I've tried
matching the power output of elite
cyclists and while those tests felt like
they were taking forever at the time for
me anyway they've really represented
these really short bursts of energy when
it comes to endurance events that last
weeks or even months on end scientists
and athletes really aren't sure what the
upper limits are on human performance
but a new study that looks at energy
expenditure in everything from multi-day
ultra marathons to pregnancy could shed
light on just how far humans can push
themselves for prolonged periods of time
to learn more about what that study
found we caught up with dr. Hermann pon
sir he's one of the lead authors on the
study I'm a professor of evolutionary
anthropology at Duke University and I
study human evolution and metabolism you
you were looking at at a pretty pretty
gob stopping endurance event right yeah
this whole study got started when bryce
carlson who is a co-author on the study
he was organizing the science team for
this crazy event called the race across
the USA and people ran from the pacific
coast to washington d.c they did a merit
of marathon a day six days a week for
five months it's thirty three thousand
plus miles 140 days I lab we specialize
in studying energy expenditure PS if we
wanted to tag along and do the
energetics of that of that race of
course we said absolutely that sounds
like you know you can't can't miss it so
that was the impetus for this whole
study we measured energy expenditures at
the beginning of the race and at the end
and as you can imagine they're burning
tons and tons of calories every day you
actually compared the race across the
USA athletes to a bunch of other data
that's been collected on athletes on on
people who do manual labor on people who
are just undergoing normal biological
processes right and and what did that
comparison show you right so we took the
data from the race across the USA
and when you place it to against
triathletes ultra marathon runners Tour
de France cyclists architects trekkers
mothers who are pregnant
scoured literature to find all the
longest-lasting highest intensity events
we could find and when you put it all
together you end up sort of mapping out
this beautiful boundary of what the
human body is capable of these are the
limits of endurance and as you might
expect you can burn a lot of calories
for a short amount of time you can burn
you can sustain fewer you know calories
burned for a couple of weeks or a couple
of months and then the level at which
you can maintain your expenditure goes
down down down as the duration goes
longer and longer it's not the same
system actually but it's analogous to
sprinting versus marathon running and
track events where you can run super
fast for 100 meters if you need to go a
mile then you have to pace yourself and
go slower that same kind of distance
versus intensity relationship only with
us we're seeing a time versus intensity
relationship and we're talking over much
longer time periods than your standard
even even your standard marathon we're
looking at things that are days weeks
long this is six marathons a week for
multiple weeks on end yeah yeah or in
pregnancy you know nine months of a
pretty intense expenditure what is the
rate that you or I or an elite athlete
or seemingly anyone right could sustain
kind of indefinitely in in an ultra
ultra ultra endurance capacity so to
speak it comes down to two and a half
times your resting metabolic rate what
does that mean so that means in real
world terms most people are burning
around 1,600 to 2,000 calories a day
just rest just at rest at baseline and
so multiply that by two and a half and
you get the level at which your body is
able to put calories back so somewhere
between 4,000 to 5,000 calories a day
would be the maximum sustainable amount
of energy expenditure at which you're
able to meet the you know whatever you
burn that day you're able to put back at
the end of the day you did find that
some people do exceed that
two-and-a-half multiplier in short
bursts or for shorter sustained efforts
right so right so you can state you can
you can go above that ceiling you can go
above that two and a half PMRF ceiling
for awhile we wouldn't consider that to
be truly sustainable forever
because if your negative energy balances
we say if you're losing weight that
obviously there's a you can't put
yourself like that forever you'll that
bad things happen
that's yeah that's a good way to put it
what do you think is keeping that limit
at 2.5 times metabolic rate it seems to
be sitting that two and a half times
basal metabolic rate limit is how
quickly your body can digest calories
and get them into your into your body in
a useful way
and we see that no matter what the
activity is if you're trekking if you're
the Tour de France if you're pregnant if
you're doing a triathlon or ultra
marathon no matter what the activity is
when we calculate how many calories
people are able to absorb into their
bodies it seems to be that
two-and-a-half basal metabolic rate
limit and that's probably telling us
about the limit at which the rate at
which you can digest calories from your
food in through your intestine
intestines through your liver and get
into your body in a useful way so you
mentioned that this is operating on a
different system from what seperates say
uh 100-meter Sprinter from a marathon
runner and it sounds to me that the
system actually has to do with your
digestion is that right if you look at
shorter events like marathons Sprint's
you know miles those seem to be based on
the limits there seem to be based on
basically on your on your muscles and
muscle ability and fatigue when we look
at these really at lung events it'sit's
the limits your guts
basically you actually approach this
problem from a couple different angles
and one of them was I was struck me is
really creative which we actually also
looked at overfeeding studies yeah can
you talk to me about why you did that
and what it showed you in science when
you're kind of doing outside of the box
Stubbs I think this study is you end up
kind of following your nose and trying
to figure out you know go where the
evidence takes you and so when we had
this sense that from the weight loss in
the endurance events that energy
absorption was a big part of this that
had us wondering well where how can we
look at studies where people have maxed
out their abilities to absorb calories
well the whole point of the study was to
maximize and push your digestive system
to the brink and absorb as many calories
as you could and as fast as possible
that would be an over feeding study so
they've been funding studies done both
in different cultural
groups where they go on the sort of
month and two long month long binges as
part of their culture it's Manuel in
their early 20s usually just trying to
pack on weight for a month or two as
well as like laboratory studies where
people are you know in a metabolic ward
and very much more sort of wet you know
clinical laboratory setting and they're
just plied with all the calories they
can get the goal is to gain as much
weight as possible it's like the biggest
winner and so the biggest loser no
matter what you do with that no matter
what how you test it we get the same
answer which is again you're able to
take in about two and a half times your
basal metabolic rate of calories again
that four to five thousand calorie range
for most people per day as the max even
when you're just jamming yourself
full of calories so given that you also
looked at studies that looked at
pregnant women does this tell us
anything new about pregnancy as a
biological process kind of puts a new
light on it for sure I don't think it's
going to change you know the way that
mothers should be cared for or take care
of their nutrition or anything like that
we're not doctors and we're not you know
some proposing some new way of taking
care of pregnant women but what I think
this does say is pregnancy takes
Mother's to the same brink the same
boundaries of human ability as a Tour de
France race as a triathlon as an
ultramarathon and so you know mom's
metabolic machinery is getting pushed to
the limit and it's just I think one more
reason that we have to be really sure
that we'd get mothers all the
nutritional help they need all the
medical help they need to keep them
healthy because it isn't it isn't easy
and I don't think that that's news to
any woman who's cut through pregnancy
but you know just one more piece of
evidence to just how tough it is on the
body comparing it to a marathon almost
it really doesn't do it justice right
it's like multiple marathons yeah that's
right the the people who ran across the
USA for five months a marathon a day
where you know not really pushing it any
harder than that a pregnant mother does
that's amazing metabolically speaking
that's incredible do you think it's
conceivable that that somebody could
exceed this limit well you know since we
published this study we've gotten you
know the Twitter's a wonderful thing
because you just have to
it's not possible to do X and then
you'll get a thousand people who want to
tell you about how they did X or
somebody that they know they'll get X
it's great actually and it's got a lot
of people excited and we're excited
about it do I think it's possible of
course you know and we you know the data
kind of brought us here and the data
will take us to some place new if that's
what what we can find
all I can say is yeah we looked as hard
as we could to look at find all the high
intensity long last endurance activities
we could find that had any kind of you
know credible measures of expenditure on
them so is it possible sure
and hopefully I'll get a chance to see
it happen and and then the slants will
go on from there for those of us who
aren't running six marathons a week for
multiple weeks on end what is the what
is the takeaway for the study well the
takeaway is this one is that there are
real limits to what your body can do and
we can now map that out you don't have
to run the you know an ultra marathon or
be in the Tour de France to potentially
you know be kind of coming up against
these limits right so I think that for a
lot of people out there who are
recreational athletes and love to push
themselves
I think this tells you maybe some
guidance about what you can expect your
body to be able to handle over the long
term thank you so much for talking with
us this was a lot of fun yeah it was a
great conversation Thanks